Police Department
Partners in the ambulance
yeah I got more partners coming
foreign
foreign
[Music]
yeah that's me
please
foreign
police
[Applause]
Police Department
shots fired
shots fired inside the door stairwell
I'm not hit but they're shooting through
the door
upstairs
three bullets
three or three
yeah right there okay police
you're okay please
come up and stand stay back stay back
close the door
all right
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
here
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right
boys three or four
sorry all right get me a rifle or two up
here
the purple shots are coming from
apartment 318 on the northeast corner
police
here
what the fuck we're good we're good
you got a rifle get it on that door 318
I mean I mean
American or something
like crazy
okay
okay
a shield and then we got a Bluetooth
please
[Music]
come out your apartment door with your
hands up there oh if you already knew
why don't you come out your apartment
door with your hands up you're under
arrest we're not going anywhere
[Music]
you understood The Voice come on outside
come out your apartment with your hands
up I don't care we're not going anywhere
you're under arrest
[Music]
no that's come out the apartment with
your hands up we're not going anywhere
let's go out the apartment door keeping
your hands up you're under arrest we're
not going anywhere
Mr sunberg we need you to come out and
cooperate with us we don't want to hurt
you we just want to go home
we want to make sure you get the help
you need come on out
come on out
sir can you come out your apartment door
with your hands up you're under arrest
I don't know he's talking to somebody on
the phone he he's very uncooperative
with me
come on come on your apartment door with
your hands up who you are before
Minneapolis Police you're under arrest
come on with your hands up
Andrew come out your apartment with your
hands up
you're under arrest it's a Minneapolis
Police
[Music]
[Music]
1090 is threatening to shoot the
officers and he's breaking up some of
his windows
hey Connor just make sure you are not
we don't even need to be in
that's what we got Apu for
in fact Conan when I have you go over
there
there's a gunshot
109 shots fired two shots so far
the officers
he just went tucked in
right side
foreign
can't see it
that might be a gun it's got a cell
phone
what's that camera
you want it on yeah
it's on
something around in there
Gone Gone
[Music]
two shot so far